salut c'est Hugo aujourd'hui on explore
en profondeur la thématique du
changement climatique et pour cela on
reçoit une personne que l'on ne présente
plus Jean-Marc jankovicii ingénieur et
consultant dans un tout nouveau format
d'entretien long bonjour Jean-Marc
jancovissi bonjour Jean-Marc jancovissi
c'est l'homme qui a conçu le bilan
carbone qui est devenue une référence
mondiale aujourd'hui pour mesurer la
quantité de gaz à effet de serre
produite par chaque organisation et
notamment donc les entreprises dans le
cadre de leur activité il est le
fondateur de carbone 4 une société qui
aide les entreprises à diminuer leurs
émissions et du shift project une assaut
qui œuvre pour la transition énergétique
il enseigne par ailleurs aux mines
parytech et il est aussi membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat bref devant moi
un CV plutôt rempli et puis quelques
gourmandises du Fitzroy abasti merci à
eux pour l'accueil voyez cette interview
comme une danse introduction sur le
sujet de l'énergie l'idée étant de mieux
comprendre les enjeux mais si après vous
voulez creuser certains sujets
précisément et bien je vous renvoie à
d'autres interview de Jean-Marc
jankovissi en description pour mieux
comprendre son regard sur chacun des
points beaucoup plus en détail allez
sans plus plus tarder on est
parti quelles sont les conséquences
d'une hausse des températures globales
de 1,5 2 2,5°gr à l'échelle de de la
planète alors l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles on a cette difficulté c'est
que comme tous les animaux et nous
sommes des animaux on a beaucoup de mal
à échapper à ce que nos sens nous
racontent et nos sens ils nous disent
pas ce que c'est qu'une moyenne en ce
moment on est capable avec notre peau
par exemple de d'apprécier la
température qui fait dans cette pièce à
cette heure-ci et en ce moment même on
n'est pas du tout capable d'apprécier la
température qui fait à adélaï à tombouou
ou à Brasilia donc en fait une moyenne
ça parle pas du tout à nos sens on
comprend pas alors je vais prendre un
premier exemple pour faire comprendre
qu'une variation de température même de
quelques degrés ça peut être massif si
je prends votre propre corps qui est un
système complexe très complexe et bien
si je modifie votre température
intérieure de 1,5°gr et que j'attends
suffisamment longtemps vous allez finir
par mourir d'accord parce que vous
pouvez pas vivre indéfiniment à 385 et
bien pour le système climatique c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que en fait
un déplacement de moyenne de quelques
degrés appliqué à système complexe en
fait ça engendre énormément de désordre
et ça engendre localement des variations
de température qui sont considérablement
supérieures à la variation de la moyenne
B a une petite précision s'impose pour
que tout le monde ait le contexte et je
me permettrai de donner deux trois
éléments de contexte comme ça lors de
l'interview pour que tout le monde
puisse suivre ce dont parle ici
Jean-Marc jancovissi c'est donc d'une
hausse de 2°gr de la température moyenne
de la planète par rapport à la période
pré-industrielle entre 1850 et 1900
selon les derniers éléments du GC si le
rythme actuel des rejets de CO2 reste
constant on pourrait arriver à plus
1,5°gr dès 2040 et à plus 2 degr en 2060
soit dans 37 ans on l'a vu par exemple
encore la semaine dernière en France
hein avec une vague de chaleur
extrêmement importante et en fait c'est
ce genre de chose qui va se multiplier
avec l'élévation de température donc
aujourd'hui pour parler chiffres la
moyenne planétaire s'est élevé de 1,2°g
en gros avec 1,2°r il y a à peu près 15
% des coraux tropicaux qui sont déjà
morts on voit des incendis au Canada qui
éradique en une année l'équivalent de la
surface de la grècee Grèce ou d'ailleurs
ça a beaucoup brûlé aussi on voit des
inondations catastrophiques se produire
encore pas plus tard que il y a quelques
jours en Libye on voit des inondations
catastrophiques se produire au Pakistan
l'année dernière des sécheresses
catastrophiques se produireent un peu
partout et cetera donc en fait
l'élévation de température en elle-même
elle ne nous dit rien l'élvation de
température moyenne euh ce qui va nous
dire quelque chose c'est tous les
événements qui vont à la suite euh et je
pourrais parler euh des zones de des
zones endémiques de certaines maladies
qui sont en train de se déplacer je
pourrais parler de l'affaiblissement des
récoltes les les Espagnols par exemple
ils vont perdre 80 % de leur écolte de
céréales cette année d'accord donc là on
parle plus de 20 degr on parle de 80 %
de la de de ce qui pousse dans les
champs qui pousse plus bon donc c'est ce
genre de chose que qui va se multiplier
et à 1,5°gr on aurait ça en encore
amplifié alors quelque chose qu'il faut
comprendre et ben ça c'est pareil c'est
pas intuitif c'est que les dégâts du
réchauffement climatique sont pas
proportionnels à l'élévation de
température tous autant que nous sommes
on est habitué tous les jours à des
règles de proportionnalité d'accord 1 kg
de carotte 2,50 € 2 kg de carottte 5 €
d'accord je deux fois plus deux fois
plus bon c'est pas du tout comme ça que
ça marche avec le climat si l'élévation
de température double donc on passe de
de de 1°gr à 2°gr les dégâts ne font pas
que ne font pas que doubler ils vont
être multipliés par 100 par 1000 enfin
je dire exponentiel ouais enfin c'est ou
hyperbolique enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est quelque chose qui va augmenter
considérablement plus vite que
l'élévation de température et là je peux
reprendre le parallèle de votre corps
entre une élévation de votre température
interne de 1°gr et de 5°g 5°gr c'est pas
5 fois plus grave que 1°gr c'est vous
êtes mort bon euh alors que 1 degré bon
c'est ça vous arrive transitoirement
c'est pas très méchant donc c'est bien
ça qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
les conséquences du réchauffement c'est
que c'est ça va beaucoup beaucoup plus
vite que l'élévation de température
alors à 2 degrés pour prendre quelques
autres exemples la totalité des coros
tropicaux sont morts à 2°gr probablement
plus de la moitié de la forêt française
est morte à 2 degrés on perd en moyenne
20 % d'humidité des sols sur tout le
pouretour du bassin méditerranéen France
comprise et sa et peut-être même plus
voilà quelques exemples de de
conséquence d'une élévation de de 2 degr
d'ors et déjà même à 1 vir quelque chose
degré on a déjà mis en route par exemple
la fonte du Grenland et donc maintenant
il suffit d'attendre quelques siècles et
on sait que l'océan mondial monta d'au
moins 3 à 6 m voilà rien qu'à cause de
ça voilà donc voilà voilà quelques
exemples et c'est peut-être un élément à
à rappeler qui est important ici c'est
là on a évoqué beaucoup de conséquences
sur la planète au sens on parle
d'élévation du niveau de la mer on parle
de fond des glaces on parle de on parle
d'incendie qui ont forcément un impact
sur sur les forêts de d'assèchement des
sols ou autres mais c'est ce lien entre
l'impact sur la sur la planète qui est
réelle sur la biodiversité et cetera et
et bien l'espèce humaine si on peut le
définir comme ça c'est peut-être aussi
un élément qui est parfois mal compris
le fait que oui c'est pas juste le
niveau de la mer qui monte et puis voilà
il monte c'est tout un tas de
conséquences sur notre quotidien et
alors par exemple même avec une
élévation de température de 2 degrés ce
qu'on appelle les submersions marines
c'est-à-dire je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez parce que vous êtes pardon de
le dire un peu jeune mais la tempête
xintia qui avait eu lieu en France et
qui a causé à la faute sur mer si ma
mémoire est bonne plusieurs dizaines de
morts parce que il y a une vague de cru
alors il y a une dépression qui fait
monter le niveau de la mer une tempête
qui pousse les la houle et les vagues
vers l'intérieur et tout ça a fait la
submersion d'un lotissement
pavillonnaire et bien ce genre de
phénomène rien qu'avec une élévation de
2 degrés il y a des endroits sur la côte
en Méditerranée où ça va être multiplié
par plusieurs centaines la fréquence de
ce genre d'événement donc c'est c'est ça
en fait l'impact sur les sociétés
humaines qu'est-ce que ça va être ça va
être des déstabilisations économiques
politique si ça pousse moins bien on va
se retrouver avec des problèmes de
10ette alimentair c'est-à-dire
d'inflation alimentaire massive et on
voit déjà le problème que ça cause
aujourd'hui voir éventuellement de
famine dans un certain nombre de pays
dans le monde et ça c'est des
déstabilisateurs politiques massifs donc
ça pose la question du maintien de la
démocratie par exemple le réchauffement
climatique peut très bien avoir la peau
de la démocratie dans un certain nombre
d'endroits ça pose la question de
l'espérance de vie parce que si on mange
pas assez ou si on a les maladies qui se
mettent à se propager ou si on a plus
les infrastructures qui nous permettent
de de d'exercer notre solidarité
aujourd'hui il faut bien voir que les
infrastructures c'est ce qui permet de
manger ici quand ça pousse plus ici mais
que ça pousse encore là ça s'appelle des
moyens de transport par exemple et bien
dans un monde dans lequel les
infrastructures sont très affaibli parce
que il y a des perturbations externes en
permanence cette solidarité que nous
avons et qui qui est un élément de
résilience qui permet aux gens de
continuer à manger à se déplacer et
cetera va s'affaiblir alors tout ça
c'est un peu la bouteille à l'encre
c'est très difficile de faire une
projection précise en disant à 1,58°gr
d'élévation de température le 4 janvier
2067 voilà ce qui peut se passer
personne va vous faire un truc comme ça
ce qui est une des diff ulté parce que
on est obligé de décider en étant un peu
dans le brouillard voilà ça fait partie
de ça fait partie de la règle du jeu
mais on sait quand même par comparaison
avec les variations climatiques dans le
passé que quelques degrés de variation
siècle c'est inédit notre espèce n'a
jamais connu ça depuis qu'elle existe et
c'est quelque chose qui aurait des
conséquences absolument massives quand
on commence à regarder un peu sur un
certain nombre de choses pratiques et
donc ça aurait des conséquences
absolument massives sur la stabilité des
sociétés humaines leur prospérité
l'espérance de vie des individus les
régimes politiques dans lesquels on
vivrait et cetera donc on va voir
différents points aujourd'hui sur ces
sur ces sujets là bon mais avant ça il y
a une question qui me trotte quand même
pas mal dans la tête depuis l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron la France on est dans
quelle situation on est parmi les pays
d'Europe qui ont le moins d'émission de
CO2 par habitant ça c'est un argument
qui revient souvent la France serait
responsable de moins de 1 % des
émissions de gaz et effet de serre
mondial c'est-à-dire bien moins que la
Chine ou encore les États-Unis seulement
et bien ce chiffre il est critiqué car
il ne tient pas compte des émissions
importées c'est-à-dire donc le CO2 est
mis dans d'autres pays mais pour
produire des biens qui sont ensuite
achetés et consommés en France bref
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous répondez
du coup à ces à ces éléments qui
reviennent souvent et qui j'ai
l'impression que pousse certaines
personnes à se à décourager ou à se dire
finalement on est on est rien du tout
quoi pour n'importe quel pays vous
pouvez toujours découper en suffisamment
petit bout pour que chaque bout
représente moins de 20 %. si je prends
les États-Unis je peux regarder les
États-Unis comme une somme de plus de 50
États et à ce moment chaque État fait
moins de 1 % voilà donc c'est c'est
toujours facile de découper en petit
bout et donc n'importe quel américain
peut dire bah moi moi je suis le citoyen
de l'état de louisian ou de l'État du
Wisconsin donc c'est moins de 1 % donc
et d'ailleurs à l'inverse on pourrait
regrouper la France à l'échelle
européenne exactement voilà comment
est-ce que il faut raisonner selon moi
la la première chose c'est que si tout
le monde pense comme ça on fera jamais
rien et donc c'est les emmerdements qui
vont résoudre le problème parce qu'il
faut bien voir que on n pas l'éternité
devant nous et que l'idée que on peut ne
pas agir et conserver le monde actuel
est une idée qu'il faut sortir de la
tête si on n'agit pas on conserve pas le
monde actuel du reste même si on agit on
va pas conserver le monde actuel mais si
on agit on conservera quelque chose qui
sera plus proche du monde actuel que si
on n'agit pas il faut bien voir
également alors ça rebondit sur la
question précédente mais que les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
c'est pas des trucs qui vont se faire de
manière progressive la bonne idée qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est ce qui se passe
en Espagne c'est-à-dire tout d'un coup
les récoltes qui disparaisse ce qui se
passe au Maroc c'est-à-dire tout d'un
coup une sécheresse monstrueuse et des
problèmes agricoles ce qui se passe en
là où il y a des inondations massives
alors il y a pas que en lib hein il y en
a il y en a un peu partout dans le monde
et à ce moment vous avez j'ai envie de
dire le mardi qui est très différent du
lundi et en fait les conséquences d'un
réchauffement climatique non maîtrisé
c'est des marches d'escalier sur
lesquels on va se casser la figure de
manière croissante en se faisant à
chaque fois beaucoup plus mal d'accord
c'est c'est c'est comme ça que ça va se
produire et donc à tout moment on peut
avoir une très mauvaise surprise qui va
nous faire regretter le fait de pas nous
y être mis avant donc une fois que j'ai
dit ça et donc l'inaction est un est un
jeu auquel tout le monde perd la bonne
question c'est comment est-ce que on
passe correctement à l'action en fait le
seul Paris gagnant c'est celui de se
dire on va se mettre à l'action et comme
les hommes sont des animaux miméti les
femmes aussi du reste et bien à ce
moment on a une petite chance que ça
crée par effet d'émulation le passage à
l'action d'autres personnes et du reste
on le constate déjà aujourd'hui dans le
monde il y a une forme d'interconnexion
des gens commencent à dire faut passer à
l'action ici et il y en a d'autres qui
disent oui oui oui il faut passer à
l'action là et cetera et même aux
États-Unis et en Chine il y a un certain
nombre de gens disant il faudrait qu'on
se remu les fesses donc c'est c'est
c'est pas on peut pas dire juste c'est
bon oui les actes de chaque pays ne sont
pas isolés finalement il y a homogène
des pays c'est pas des tout homogènes
donc en fait le Paris perdant c'est de
se dire on reste les bras croisés en
attendant que les autres s'y mettent
parce que si tout le monde brisonne
comme ça on avance pas est-ce que c'est
trop tard selon vous pour sauver la
planète et qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ces échos qui reviennent souvent alors
je vais répondre déjà que sauver la
planète on s'en fout ce qui compte c'est
nous sauver nous-mêmes et que ensuite il
y a un parallèle qui vaut ce qu' vaut
mais qui est le
tabac à quelques moment que vous
décidiez d'arrêter de fumer c'est
toujours une bonne idée euh bah là c'est
exactement pareil à quelques moment
qu'on décide d'en rajouter au problème
ça sera toujours une bonne chose et
notamment encore une fois comme le
problème est un problème dans lequel le
10e de degré supplémentaire de
réchauffement amènera beaucoup plus que
un diè d'emmerdement supplémentaire
c'est bien ça qu'il faut garder en tête
et bien il faut il faut vraiment à
chaque fois faire ce qu'on peut pour
éviter d'en rajouter encore plus et je
le redis de toute façon c'est notre
intérêt égoïste et c'est quelque chose
auquel on va pas couper à cause de la
dépression des combustibles fossiles
donc de toute façon il y a pas de c trop
tard à tout moment c'est toujours et
plus on attend plus on devra agir dans
un monde qui se sera désorganisé donc ça
sera encore plus difficile
qu'aujourd'hui voilà donc c'est c'est
malheureusement enfin ou heureusement
plutôt il n'est jamais trop tard pour se
mettre à l'action coordonnée parce
qu'encore une fois c'est ilusoir de
penser que demain ça sera beaucoup plus
facile qu'aujourd'hui on va justement du
coup parler des solutions des
différentes grandes thématiques et
notamment du coup on va parler d'énergie
pour cela on va refaire un point rapide
ici aujourd'hui le pétrole il est
utilisé absolument partout on en utilise
pour se déplacer pour se chauffer pour
pour faire fonctionner notre économie
bref il est ultra présent aujourd'hui
dans notre quotidien et ce n'est pas
Jean-Marc janovissi qui dira le
contraire ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que le pétrole est absolument
partout dans nos vies aujourd'hui sans
le pétrole il y aurait pas eu le 20e
siècle et à forceori pas le début du 21e
le pétrole est dans ce qu'on mange enfin
pétrole et gaz parce que nous mangeons
des choses qui ont été cultivées avec
des tracteurs fertilisés avec des
engrais et défendu contre les petites
bestioles avec des phytosanitaires tout
ça c'est du pétrole le pétrole est dans
nos vêtements parce que toutes les
fibres en poly maachin chouettees que
nous avons sur nous et le nylon ça c'est
du pétrole et même quand c'est du coton
ce qui est le cas de mon t-shirt il a
été teint avec du pétrole transporté
avec du pétrole assemblé avec du pétrole
le pétrole est dans le système mondial
de transport et notamment les camions et
les bateaux et sans les camions et les
bateaux vous auriez en France plus une
casserole plus un téléphone ce qui
serait beaucoup plus grave que les
casseroles plus une caméra pour nous
filmer et plus un bout de moquette il
est absolument partout le pétrole on se
rend pas compte mais il est absolument
partout il y a pas un truc qu'on fasse
dans la journée auquel on y échappe il
est dans les rouges à lèvres et les
cosmétiques il enfin absolument partout
le problème c'est qu'on sait depuis
longtemps que le pétrole n'est pas
illimité qu'un jour on en aura de moins
en moins puis plus du tout d'où du coup
ma question qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quand ce sera le cas est-ce que son prix
va exploser sortir du pétrole encore une
fois c'est toucher à tout partout tout
le temps ça revient à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est un c'est un projet
de société c'est un projet c'est un
projet systémique la seule chose qu'il
faut garder présente à l'esprit alors ça
c'est un peu perturbant en particulier
pour ceux qui ont fait des études
d'économie c'est qu'il n'y a pas de lien
de long terme entre la quantité de
pétrole disponible et son prix on se dit
tiens s'il y a moins de pétrole le prix
va monter en fait non c'est pas ça qui
va se passer si vous prenez quelque
chose qui n'est pas essentiel au
fonctionnement de l'économie prenons les
sacs à main par exemple bon si vous avez
moins de sac à main ça casse pas
l'économie bon il y a juste moins de sac
à main mais ça touche pas à la
solvabilité du consommateur d'accord
donc le prix du sac à main monte
effectivement comme ça que ça se passe
mais si vous avez moins de pétrole comme
c'est quelque chose qui est essentiel à
l'économie parce que c'est le système de
transport si vous avez moins de
transport vous avez moins de production
si vous avez moins de pétrole vous
cassez une partie de l'économie du coup
la solvabilité de votre consommateur
baisse parce que si l'économie se
contracte B les gens gagnent moins
d'argent et si vous avez à la fois moins
de pétrole et une solvabilité du
consommateur qui a baissé vous savez pas
si le nouveau prix d'équilibre il va
être au-dessus en dessous à côté vous
savez pas où il est et en fait à chaque
fois que il y a des gens qui qui
cessaient à prévoir le prix du pétrole
quelques années après il se plante
toujours à cause de ça parce que en fait
il y a pas d'élasticité pour prendre le
terme un peu technique il y a pas de
lien entre le prix du pétrole et son
volume donc si le pétrole se contracte
aujourd'hui la seule chose que vous êtes
capable de dire c'est que l'économie se
contracte si le pétrole se contracte en
volume si vous en avez moins il y a
moins de barils qui sortent de terre et
à ce moment l'économist par du coup
moins moins d'énergie disponible si on
résume très très schématiquement donc
forcément moins de produit et l'énergie
c'est quoi c'est les machines qui
travaillent pour nous c'est ça l'énergie
en fait he c'est pas vous qui buvez le
pétrole ni moi du reste là c'est pas du
pétrole qu' y a dans les carafes ça sera
pas terrible et c'est pas vous qui
mangez le charbon donc ni les gens qui
nous écoutent donc en fait l'énergie
c'est juste la nourriture des machines
et si vous avez moins d'énergie vous
avez moins de machin qui travaillent et
comme dans l'économie moderne c'est les
machines qui bossent et bien ça veut
dire que on a moins de production c'est
aussi simple que ça ça c'est assez
facile à comprendre et donc moins de
pétrole c'est pas un prix qui monte
indéfiniment c'est une économie qui se
contracte selon Jean-Marc jankovici donc
le prix du pétrole n'augmentera pas
forcément à mesure qu'il deviendra plus
rare en Revan ce qu'il dit donc c'est
que plus le pétrole sera rare moins on
pourra faire fonctionner les machines
dans les usines moins on pourra produire
donc de quantités importantes de biens
de consommation en tout genre que ce
soit des pulls ou alors des micros du
coup quelles sont les les options que
vous dessinez que vous voyez pour
réduire le plus rapidement possible
parce que forcément il y a une urgence
là-dessus les émissions de gaz effet de
ser et qui sont indispensables selon
vous alors quand on regarde d'où
viennent les émissions de gaz et effet
de serre dans le monde vous en avez un
quart qui vient de la production
électrique au charbon et au gaz ça si on
regarde la partie française c'est un
problème qu'on a à peu près réglé
puisque on a quasiment plus de charbon
donc encore un peu mais et on n pas
beaucoup de gaz bon à l'échelle
européenne c'est moins vrai mais à
l'échelle française c'est un problème
qu'on a quasiment réglé après vous avez
un bout des émissions de gaz à effet de
ser qui viennent des transports ça c'est
quelque chose qui compte signifi dans
les émissions françaises donc là ça veut
dire que il faut s'attaquer à la
question de la voiture individuelle
fonctionnant au carburant d'origine
fossile il faut s'intéresser et on
s'intéresse pas assez au problème des
camions parce que les gens ont des
jambes donc même SS gueulent s'ils ont
moins de voiture ils se déplaceront
quand même les marchandises n'ont pas de
jambes et il faut bien comprendre que si
demain matin on supprimait les camions
toutes les villes meurent de faim a plus
moyen d'acheminer la nourriture il y
voilà il y a plus de chaîne logistique
sur la nourriture et donc on mange plus
il y a la question du du du carburant
dans les avion et dans les bateaux et là
il va falloir hiérarchiser aussi est-ce
que c'est plus important s'il nous reste
un litre de diesel de le mettre dans un
camion pour manger ou de le mettre dans
un avion pour aller faire un tour je
sais pas où bon on va devoir gérer alors
c'est un peu faire le triste cire de
dire ça mais on va devoir gérer une
forme de hiérarchie des renoncement
voilà c'est on va devoir gérer ça et des
alternatives donc a la question du
pétrole qui est une question importante
il y a la question du chauffage chez
nous qui est une question importante
donc les chaudières domestiques au gaz
et au fou et puis a la question
industrielle alors la question
industrielle elle est elle compte à
l'intérieur de nos frontières mais elle
compte beaucoup à l'extérieur de nos
frontières ce t-shirt c'est un fruit de
la mondialisation d'accord il a été
fabriqué avec des trucs pour parties qui
viennent de l'extérieur des frontières
euh c'estes micros aussi et même le la
la tranche de cake là parce que
là-dedans vous avez des céréales qui ont
été cultivées avec des engrais azotés
l'engrais c'est sont fabriqué avec du
gaz le gaz est pas chez nous donc en
fait euh il y a des émissions qui
viennent de l'extérieur des frontières
beaucoup dans tous les objets de la vie
courante et ça évidemment c'est plus
difficile de les réduire parce que parce
qu'on les a pas sous la main voilà d'où
la notion de réindustrialisation à
laquelle on parle dont on parle de temps
en temps qui consisterait à refaire les
trucs chez nous pour les avoir sous la
main et essayer de les faire entre
guillemets un peu plus proprement que
quand c'est fait ailleurs donc c'est
c'est s'attaquer encore une fois à à à
tout partout en France c'est beaucoup de
chauffage beaucoup les transports un peu
l'industrie enfin même pas mal
l'industrie et pas mal l'agriculture
également même si c'est pas des du gaz
carbonique donc du CO2 qui est mis par
l'agriculture mais d'autres types de gaz
euh il y a également un sujet agricole
et donc sur les sources d'énergie on a
bien compris que le pétrole évidemment
c'est une ressource limitée et
évidemment très polluante qui a un enjeu
d'en d'en sortir déjà très rapidement si
question làdessus est-ce qu'on
retrouvera un jour une énergie aussi
performante selon vous que le pétrole et
donc sur la cette transition là quels
sont dans le mix énergétique qu'on
imagine les éléments essentiel
aujourd'hui selon vous pour pour s'en
sortir alors quand on parle des énergies
non fossiles des énergies qu'on appelle
décarboné souvent il y a deux grandes
familles qui sont les énergies
renouvelables et je les mets
délibérément au pluriel les énergies
nucléaires parce qu'il y a plusieurs
manières d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire
les énergies renouvelables sont des
énergies qu'on connaît depuis très
longtemps puisque c'est les énergies qui
ont accompagné l'histoire de l'humanité
jusqu'à la découverte des énergies
fossiles l'ancienne marine était
propulsée avec du vent il y avait des
moulins à vant et des moulins à eau
partout en Europe au moment du Moyen-Âge
enfin déjà dès l'Antiquité il y avait
des moulins à eau he dès les Romains
connaissaient ça très bien il y en avait
les Chinois connaissaient également très
bien la force motrice de l'eau le bois
est utilisé depuis extrêmement longtemps
l'attraction animale qui est une énergie
renouvelable était tilisée depuis
extrêmement longtemps et cetera donc il
faut bien voir que les énergies
renouvelables c'est les énergies qui
préexistaient avant les énergies
fossiles et la raison pour laquelle on
est passé des renouvelables au fossiles
c'est pas parce qu'on était tous des
crétins patentés malfaisant ayant envie
de polluer l'atmosphère c'est juste
parce que physiquement c'est beaucoup
plus efficace on peut promener beaucoup
plus d'énergie avec soi avec les
énergies fossiles par exemple le pétrole
est l'énergie qui a la plus grande
densité énergétique par unité de volume
de toutes cell qu'on con quand vous avez
1 lre juste vous avez le droit de
promener 1 L avec vous et ben c'est en
mettant du pétrole dans ce litre que
vous avez le plus d'énergie avec vous si
vous émettez du charbon si vous
émettetez du gaz si vous mettez du bois
et à force si vous mettez si vous mettez
du vent pour un litre d'air et ben ça
fait pas beaucoup d'énergie donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle les énergies
fossiles sont celles qui ont permis
l'essort industriel il y a deux siècles
avant on avait des génies archimè et
mozar étaient des génies sauf que on
avait pas les énergies fossiles et donc
même avec des génies on n arrivrivait
pas à faire une civilisation
industrielle donc les énergies fossiles
on y est passé parce que c'était
beaucoup plus simple d'avoir des grandes
quantités de transformations
l'environnement avec des petits volumes
ou des petites quantités de matière
voilà alors évidemment toutes les
énergies renouvlaables sont pas
identiques l'hydroélectricité par
exemple c'est beaucoup plus simple à
utiliser que le vent euh donc si vous
êtes en Norvège ou en Suède vous pouvez
avoir énormément d'électricité
hydraulique euh c'est facile par contre
le bois c'est déjà un peu plus compliqué
il faut avoir des grandes surfaces de
forêt al c'est pareil si vous êtes en
Suède he 100 millions d'habitants sur
350000 km² vous pouvez avoir énormément
de bois dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique si vous êtes belge un peu
plus difficile avec la même quantité d'
habitant sur beaucoup moins beaucoup
beaucoup moins de territoire il existe
donc des énergies décarbonées que
Jean-Marc janovici vient de citer la
biomasse avec le bois l'olien avec le
vent l'hydraulique avec les barrages
mais on a aussi une autre énergie
importante pour Jean-Marc jeancovissi et
puis après vous avez les énergies
nucléaires alors les énergies
nucléaaires on des enfin je vais prendre
la fission c'est celle qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui ça consiste à casser un gros
noyau en deux en obtenant ainsi beaucoup
d'énergie alors l'avantage c'est que
c'est extrêmement dense énergétiquement
vous avez autant d'énergie dans la
fission d'un g d'uranium que dans la
combustion d'une tonne de pétrole
d'accord donc vous avez un rapport de 1
à 1 million sur la quantité de matière
que vous manipulez entre la combustion
et laffission donc ça veut dire que
l'énergie nucléaire occupe peu d'espace
parce que vous avez besoin de quelques
installations pour produire massivement
de l'énergie peu de matière du coup même
si c'est des cochonneries fait en volume
ou en poids peu de déchets puis que vous
avez manipulé peu de matière par contre
ça ne fait entre guillemets que de
l'électricité donc derrière vous avez la
rigidité d'emploi de l'électricité vous
pouvez l'utiliser là où il y a un réseau
électrique et pour la stocker en dehors
de là où il y a un réseau électrique
c'est un sujet parce que le stockage de
l'électricité c'est pas simple d'accord
donc voilà en gros les les les les
énergies qui sont à notre main si la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
qu'on va conserver exactement le monde
actuel avec les énergies décarbonées que
je viens d'évoqué en quelques décennies
la réponse est non c'est juste pas
possible ce qui veut dire que l'autre
pendant de l'action qui est absolument
indispensable est ce qu'on appelle la
sobriété c'est-à-dire arriver à être
heureux avec moins de truc matériel et
donc forcément de votre côté vous
estimez que le si je je schématise he
mais que le nucléaire est quand même
assez indispensable aujourd'hui bah pour
s'en sortir dans cette transition là
sans émettre trop de de gaz à effet de
serre c'est un élément du coup qui est
combiné à d'autres énergies à des
énergies renouvelables qu'on vient
d'évoquer ici quels sont les risques
selon vous d'un monde sans énergie
nucléaire aujourd'hui typiquement dans
le cas de la France il est celui d'un
effondrement économique et social
accéléré en fait l'énergie qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est la capacité à mettre des
machines en mouvement et je le redis
aujourd'hui notre système productif il
est basé sur des machines bon donc si
vous avez moins d'énergie à donner à
manger aux machine vous avez un système
productif qui se contracte plus vite
donc en fait avec moins d'électricité
globalement ou moins d'énergie
globalement plus la baisse est rapide
plus vous avez pour prendre un terme
économique une contraction économique
rapide plus les revenus des gens
baissent vite parce que en fait ce qui
fait nos revenus aujourd'hui c'est la
production des machines hein on ne peut
ça vous rappellera vos vieux cours
d'économie hein en macroéconomie la
somme des revenus et la somme de ce
qu'on peut consommer c'est la même chose
hein moins il y a d'énergie moins il y a
de production moins il y a de revenus et
donc du coup plus la plus les problèmes
sociaux arrivent vite c'est plus
difficile de donner un toit à tout le
monde c'est plus difficile
éventuellement de donner à manger à ceux
qu'on pas de quoi manger on le voit en
ce moment avec les associations
caritatif qui disent qu'elles ont du mal
et cetera donc en fait c'est ce genre de
problème qui s'accélère alors évidemment
ça peut paraître très étonnant aux gens
qui nous écoutent en disant cette
histoire moins de réacteur nucléaire ça
fait plus de problèmes au resto du cœur
ben oui il y a quelque chose de ça bon
c'est pas aussi simple le mais il y a
quelque chose de ça sauf à se dire que
on irait de retour à ouvrir des
centrales à charbon ou quoi pour palier
ce ce manque mais du coup c'est c sa en
plus on a pas le charbon chez nous le
charbon ça voyage mal c'est un pondéreux
solide ça voyage pas très bien le
charbon donc les pays qui ont du charbon
s'en servent beaucoup les pays qui ont
pas de charbon s'en servent pas tant que
ça parce que ça voyage pas tant que ça
le pendant d'une décrue énergétique trop
rapide c'est une déstabilisation de
notre système social et économique trop
rapide et à ce moment on se retrouve
avec d'autres risques et d'autres inconv
que ceux du nucléaire et en fait
l'arbitrage qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
faire aujourd'hui dans notre esprit
parce qu'on sort d'un monde confortable
où en gros on se dit bah si tel objet
est risqué on se passe de l'objet et on
en aura un autre qui rendra les mêmes
services en étant moins risqué c'est
comme ça qu'on raisonne en fait il faut
bien comprendre que dans un monde sous
contrainte de ressources qui est celui
vers lequel on se dirige si on n pas tel
objet qu'on considère comme risqué on ai
on a éventuellement rien d'autre et à ce
moment la question ou rien d'autre dans
les mêmes dans les mêmes ordres de
grandeur il y a un sousdébat au sein des
énergies décarbonées qui consiste à dire
mais c'est pas grave en fait si on fait
pas de nucléaire on frera plus vite des
éoliennes des panneaux solaires et
cetera et en fait quand on regarde ce
qui peut être fait et dans quel délai on
se rend compte que cet argument il est
quand même on n'est pas certain d'y
arriver du tout on est beaucoup mieux si
on fait les deux en même temps en fait
c'est quand même comme ça que il faut
réfléchir et donc la la les deux les
deux situations à comparer c'est les
risques du nucléaire si on en fait avec
les risques de ne pas avoir de sources
d'énergie décarboné qui permet de
stabiliser la société et en fait moi la
conclusion que j'en ai tirée après avoir
regardé ça un peu sous toutes les
coutures depuis longtemps c'est que ne
pas avoir de nucléaire est globalement
une situation plus risquée qu'avoir du
nucléaire même si c'est pas comme ça que
la majeure partie des gens raisonnent
pour nuancer les opposants nucléaire
aujourd'hui soulligne notamment un
risque d'accident nucléaire comme il a
pu avoir à Fukushima au Japon mais
là-dessus je vous mets des liens en
description pour comprendre l'état du
débat entre guillemets sur la question
du nucléaire aujourd'hui et maintenant
on va parler non pas de la production de
l'énergie en tant que telle mais de ce
qu'on en fait il y a forcément un autre
volet qui est la question de
l'utilisation de cette énergie là et
donc là on pourrait là aussi en parler
pendant pendant longtemps un des aspects
qu'on a qu'on a évoqué à l'instant c'est
la question des transports un élément
forcément important Emmanuel Macron
pendant mon interview a défendu l'idée
d'un avion zéro émission c'est un
élément qu'il a qu'il a évoqué faut
changer de carburant et donc on est en
train progressivement de sortir du du
kérosène et entre maintenant et 2030
quel est notre objectif c'est d'intégrer
progressivement ce qu'on appelle les SAF
qui sont donc nos carburants durables
qu'on met dans les avions avec le le
kérosen et de de passer d'ici à 2030 à
50 % de SAF question assez simple est-ce
que ça existe vraiment un avion zéro
émission est-ce que la la réponse est
non aujourd'hui d'où viennent les
émissions du transport aérien elles
viennent de la fabrication des avions
elles viennent de la fabrication des
aéroports et puis elles viennent de
l'utilisation des avions quand ils vole
alors dans quand l'avion vole ces
émissions viennent de deux choses
différentes enfin exactement la
perturbation du climat vient de deux
choses différentes la première c'est que
quand on utilise du kérosène qui est une
molécule organique c'està-dire avec du
carbone et de l'hydrogène bah la
combustion fait de la vapeur d'eau et du
CO2 le CO2 est un gaz à effet de serre
si on remplaçait ça par un carburant qui
ne contient pas de carbone par exemple
de l'hydrogène ou si on remplacer ça par
un agrocarburant dont on dit il a fait
zéro carbone fossile à sa fabrication ce
qui est pas vrai mais c'est pas grave et
bien l'avion il émettrait encore de la
vapeur d'eau et la vapeur d'eau émise
par les avions dans la haute atmosphère
contribue également au réchauffement
climatique donc même l'avion a hydrogène
contribuerait au réchauffement
climatique à supposer qu'il soit
possible et en fait quand on regarde
bien physiquement ce que ça implique on
en fera peut-être un pour un
milliardaire un jour mais on en fera
jamais l'aviation de masse qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc en fait l'aviation zéro
carbone c'est juste pas possible
l'aviation moins carbonée qu'aujourd'hui
c'est possible mais l'aviation zéro
carbone non là-dessus donc le sujet é es
venu lors de mon interview d'Emmanuel
Macron parce que on parlait de la
question du coup de mode de transport
plus respectueux de l'environnement
j'aiévoqué notamment le fait que selon
les scientifiques notamment les derniers
rapports du GC il y a un besoin de
sobriété donc de réduire l'utilisation
notamment de de l'avion et lui répondait
que il n'imaginait pas un monde
forcément on baissait l'utilisation de
l'avion et qu'au contraire justement il
y avait des solutions d'un point de vue
technologique pour continuer à utiliser
l'avion comme avant sans simplement en
étant plus respectueux de
l'environnement selon vous qu'est-ce qui
explique que ce discours là est aussi
présent notamment de la part du du
gouvernement alors d'abord
malheureusement on est tous bien placés
pour savoir que de temps en temps le
monde futur ne correspond pas à celui
qu'on désire voilà il peut se passer
autre chose que ce dont on a vraiment
envie et en l'occurrence c'est pas parce
que Monsieur Macron n'imagine pas un
monde dans lequel ça soit plus difficile
de prendre l'avion que c'est quand même
pas ça qui va se produire donc la raison
pour laquelle beaucoup de gens sont
rétifs à ça c'est en général parce que
leur dire une partie de ce que nous
avons dans le monde qui nous environne
ne sera plus possible ça crée de
l'incertitude et l'incertitude on n'aime
pas ça c'est aussi bête que ça donc
c'est de là que vient le déniis par
exemple et c'est de là que on a besoin
de se raccrocher à des certitudes on est
bigorné comme ça et comme Monsieur
Macron il est pas capable de décrire le
système alternatif euh d'abord parce
qu'une partie de ses composantes peuvent
pas être connues avec précision et
ensuite parce que c'est pas un
spécialiste du transport aérien euh et
bien c'est beaucoup plus simple pour lui
beaucoup plus confortable
psychologiquement de dire j'imagine pas
euh mais parce que c'est la réaction
normale de beaucoup de gens en parik
j'imagine pas parce qu' effffectivement
au sens littéral du terme il n'imagine
pas c'est voilà même moi qui travaille
dessus j'imagine pas non plus dans tous
les détails hein je suis pas capable on
a fait au chire project il y a quelques
années un travail sur l'avion don le
titre était pouvoir voler en 2050 et en
fait le travail a été fait par des
ingénieurs de l'aéronaut donc des gens
qui globalement aiment plutôt l'avion
ils ont plutôt envie et la conclusion
quantitative de leur travail c'est même
en étant le plus optimiste possible sur
le gain en carburant des avions
existants les nouveaux types d'avion
avec des hélices avec de l'électricité
de l'hydrogène qu'est-ce qu'on veut et
cetera si on veut que l'aviation évolue
en ligne avec la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qu'il faut que
collectivement on est dans l'humanité
c'est moins 5 % par an il y a aucun
moyen d'échapper à une décrue
progressive du trafic aérien on limitera
la décrue du trafic aérien en étant
aussi offensif que possible sur la
technique mais ça n'évitera pas la décru
du transport aérien alors est-ce que
c'est un drame que le transport aérien
décroisse moi je pense que non et ça me
fait aussi une entrée en matière
parfaite pour évoquer le propos le plus
célèbre peut-être de Jean-Marc
jankovissi que vous avez peut-être
entendu à la télévision à la radio en
podcast c'est le suivant si on doit
répartir équitablement entre tous les
Terriens un volume de vol en avion qui
est de l'ordre du 5e ou du 10e de ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui et bien on se
retrouve avec qu vol dans une vie par
rien voilà mais alors quel calcul a fait
Jean-Marc jovissi pour arriver à se
résultat et bien voici sa réponse j'ai
fait une petite règle de TR très simple
d'abord c'est pas par français c'est par
terrien mon calcul donc j'ai considéré
que à l'arrivée un Somalien un Brésilien
un habitant du Zimbabwe et vous vous
aviez le même droit annuel à prendre
l'avion enfin le même droit dans votre
vie à prendre l'avion donc c'est pas
juste pour les Français après on peut
très bien dire bah les Somaliens qui
restent là où ils sont et nous on on va
voler plus queeux et c'est très bien
comme ça en ce moment le résultat du
calcul est pas le même la deuxième chose
que j'ai imaginé c'est que l'aviation
était en ligne avec les accords de Paris
c'est donc - 5 % de baisse tous les ans
à partir de maintenant et j'ai pas mis
énormément de progrès technologique dans
mon affaire donc j'ai imaginé qu'un vol
et mettait à peu près toujours autant
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'on aurait
beaucoup de mal à remplacer le kérosène
par autre chose et une fois que j'ai
divisé les émissions du transport aérien
globalement par je sais plus par combien
je les avais divisé 4 ou 5 un truc comme
ça et que je répartis ce qui reste entre
tous les terriens et ben ça me donne
quat vols dans une vie voilà c'était pas
une proposition en fait c'était une
question on peut retrouver la séquence
hein Salamé me dit euh à combien de vols
par vie est-ce qu'on a droit si
l'aviation et cetera je dit bon à peu
près quatre ça peut être qure ça peut
être 5 ça peut être 6 et puis après j'ai
fait le calcul et j'ai dit effectivement
à peu près quatre voilà à ce stade c'est
pas une proposition je j'insiste parce
que je dis pas il faut le faire comme ça
et puis j'ai les moyens de j'ai j'ai les
modalités techniques qui vont derrière
et cetera par contre c'est un ordre de
grandeur qui fixe les idées ça montre
bien qu'aujourd'hui prendre l'avion est
devenu un geste très habituel mais il
faut bien voir alors bon beaucoup plus
vieux que vous mais il faut bien voir
que même la génération de mes parents
prendre l'avion pour eux c'était
exceptionnel c'est c'était c'était un
geste qui était très hors du commun à
l'époque de mes parents les gens
n'avaient pas droit à quatre vols dans
une vie globalement pas du tout bon mon
père qui était pourtant un CSP+
puisqu'il était chercheur il est parti
en postdoc aux États-Unis dans les
années 50 il est parti en bateau c'était
le moyen normal de traverser
l'Atlantique à l'époque donc l'avion
pour tous tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui c'est né avec le pétrole et
il faut se faire à l'idée que ça mourra
avec le pétrole c'est-à-dire que dans le
monde d'après-demain il y aura de toute
façon quelle que soit la manière dont on
va s'y prendre
considérablement moins d'avion est-ce
que c'est très grave je considère que
non à quoi sert l'essentiel de l'avion
aujourd'hui à prendre des gens qui
habitent en ville pour aller dans une
ville à l'autre bout du monde loger dans
un hôtel qui ressemble à celui qu'ils
ont à côté de chez eux manger au même
McDo et acheter des sacs à main quand
c'est les Chinois qui est-ce que tout ça
est absolument indispensable au bonheur
humain je pas complètement alors bon on
va me dire oui mais les familles éclaté
oui ok donc il y a une partie des vol en
avion qui ont plus de prix que d'autres
et cetera et il faut bien voir que les
familles éclatées ont été rendu
possiblebl par l'ex distance de l'avion
et à ce moment-là les gens sont pas dit
ah merde peut-être qu'un jour il y aura
plus d'avion donc si on éclate les
familles j'accepte à l'avance l'idée que
peut-être un jour je verraai plus mes
proches mais malheureusement à l'horizon
de quelques dizaines d'années c'est
quand même une partie de ce qui va se
passer là on a parlé de l'avion mais
évidemment le mode de transport le plus
utilisé au quotidien c'est certainement
pas l'avion on le sait et c'est évident
il y a un enjeu d'aller sur les
transports en commun dans les
déplacements du quotidien ou alors de
prendre un vélo ou autre mais forcément
il y a certaines régions certains
territoires où c'est plus difficile
parce que il y a pas de transport en
commun qui sont aussi développés seppose
du coup la la question de la la
transition aussi pour cette partie de la
population le transport électrique et
les voitures électriques ont beaucoup
été poussées évidemment ces dernières
années elles vont continuer à l'être à
l'échelle européenne un des éléments qui
revient souvent dans les retours c'est
la question du budget associé à ces
voitures électriques parce que même avec
les aides globalement en tout cas
aujourd'hui on est encore sur un prix
moyen qui est plus élevé que pour des
voitures thermiques et on pourrait
rajouter une difficulté c'est que les
ménages modelles achète des voitures
d'occasion h donc si on veut qu'ils
achètent des voitures d'électrique il
faut qu'il trouve des voitures
électriques d'occasion et on pourrait
rajouter une autre difficulté c'est que
aujourd'hui les constructeurs font leur
marche sur les gros sur les grosses
voitures sur les gros modèles et donc ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'on est en train
d'électrifier d'abord des grosses
voitures plutôt même s'il y a quand même
des petits modèles mais je veux dire les
constructeurs mettent plutôt l'accent
sur les gros parce que c'est là qu' font
leur marge donc euh tout ça fait
beaucoup de difficulté alors quelles
sont les solutions pour inciter les gens
à se séparer de leur voiture thermique
donc à essence ou à diesel alors que on
le voit il existe aujourd'hui pas mal de
freins et alors en fait quand on regarde
la façon dont on pourrait essayer de
panacher tout ce qui est à notre
disposition pour se déplacer au
quotidien avec moins de voiture déjà
quelques chiffres euh dans le dans la
voiture les 2 tiers du kilométrage fait
par les voitures dans l'année c'est des
déplacements du quotidien un/3 c'est des
déplacements longue distance les
déterminants sont pas du tout les mêmes
la longue distance c'est pour partir en
vacances c'est des loisirs et cetera et
donc là on peut imaginer s'organiser un
peu différemment okel déplacement dure
un peu plus longtemps mais on peut
basculer sur le train on peut basculer
sur le bus et cetera et ça dépend
beaucoup de la facilité qu'on va avoir à
se déplacer au lieu de destination avec
des moyens qui s'y trouveront
disponibles selon qu'on va pouvoir ou
pas louer des vélos électriques parce
que la longue distance c'est beaucoup
les vacances les vacances c'est beaucoup
l'été donc bon il pleut moins il fait
moins froid ça peut être les services de
transport en commun à destination ça
peut être et cetera les déplacements du
quotidien c'est très différent donc
c'est les déplacements pour aller au
travail aux études faire des courses
faire du sport c'est aller à l'école et
cetera et donc ça les les moyens qui
sont à notre disposition c'est d'abord
moins de voiture avec du covoiturage des
transports en commun du vélo électrique
en particulier le vélo électrique change
la donne par rapport au vélo mécanique
j'ai envie de dire parce que ça permet
de faire des des distances plus longues
avec moins d'effort et puis c'est
l'électrification des voitures qui
restent alors la proportion de chaque
euh mode d'action varie en fonction du
tissu urbain si on est euh dans Paris
intramuros euh en fait on peut tout
faire sans voiture sans aucun problème
bon même si on est en boneu plus
compliqué quasiment de voure c'est très
clair ou en transport en commun si on
est dans en banlieu même en banlieu
parisienne on peut encore faire
énormément de choses sans voiture hein
donc en fait par contre c'est clair que
si on habite au fin fond de la Creuse
c'est plus compliqué précise que je n'ai
strictement rien contre la Creuse et que
c'est un très joli département donc
c'est c'est simplement pour dire que en
fait il faut pas voir une seule mesure
comme devant être celle qui s'impose à
la totalité des Français c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut raisonner il faut panacher
un peu différemment en fonction et
personnellement je préférerais qu'on
subventionne des petits véhicules
électriques pour les ruraux plutôt que
aujourd'hui le système subventionne
aussi des gros 44 électriques pour des
urbains qui en plus gagne ce qu'il faut
et absolument pas besoin d'être
subventionné de toute façon donc accès
les aides plutôt sur les voitures qui
seraient absolument et on pourrait les
accès et il faudrait en faire des primes
à la casse c'est-à-dire il faudrait
queon soit absolument sûr qu'il y a une
voiture thermique qui sortte du parc
quand on met une voiture électrique à la
place aujourd'hui c'est pas conçu comme
ça c'est juste un bonus à l'achat de la
voiture électrique mais c'est pas une
prime à la casse donc moi je serai pour
des primes à la casse sous condition de
ressources et éventuellement sous
conditions de lieu d'habitation donc
avoir des mesures beaucoup plus ciblées
bref selon Jean-Marc jeancovici
plusieurs pistes qu'on peut noter
d'abord le télétravail lorsque c'est
possible ensuite le covoiturage et puis
le développement d'autres modes de
transport comme le vélo électrique là
aussi quand c'est possible le train ou
encore le bus et enfin pour finir ce
qu'il vient d'expliquer des prime pour
inciter les familles les plus modestes à
se séparer de leur voiture thermique et
à la remplacer par une électrique là
aussi on avait fait des calculs au chire
project en fait en panachant toutes ces
mesures c'est-à-dire covoiturage un peu
de télétravail qui diminue les
déplacements du quotidien enfin certains
déplacement du quotidien du vélo
électrique des transports en commun et
de l'électrification des voitures en
fait en panachant tout ça on peut
arriver à baisser assez rapidement les
les émissions du transport du transport
terrestre enfin de personnes ça c'est
donc pour la question des transports
mais d'autres aspects de nos vies vont
être bouleversés avec la fin du pétrole
et le changement climatique c'est le cas
par exemple des loisirs et on va prendre
pour exemple la question du ski alors le
ski est loin d'être le sport le plus
accessible puisqu'il coûte cher mais
c'est l'un des exemples les plus
marquants comment Jean-Marc jankoviss
voit l'évolution des sports d'hivers
dans 20 à 30 ans le ski et le tourisme à
la montagne c'est aussi un enfant du
pétrole quand vous regardez le les
départements de la Savoie par exemple
Savoie et autre Savoie il faut savoir
que la moitié de leur activité
économique c'est le tourisme donc c'est
absolument considérable un économique
aussi alors que ces départements de
montagne euh avant guerre enfin avant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ça faisait
partie des départements les plus pauvres
de France parce que vous aviez de
l'agriculture de montagne vous aviez
très peu de ski hein en gros et
l'agriculture de montagne c'est pas la
plus productive hein donc vous avez des
vaches qui vont au pâurage l'été qui
restent à l'étable hiiver bon et puis
c'était une vie dure le ski en fait est
arrivé essentiellement avec le pétrole
parce que la mise à disposition pour
tout un chacun d'une voiture quand vous
regardez la quantité de gens qui une
semaine de février
arrive dans la vallée de la Tarantaise
là où vous avez TIG valder les arcs La
Plagne enfin toutes ces grandes vallées
de la Savoie et bien vous vous rendez
compte que on pourrait absolument pas
les amener en train il y aurait juste
pas la capacité ferroviaire la quantité
de train qu'il faudrait avoir par jour
juste hallucinante et donc dans un monde
avec considérablement moins de voitures
et bien vous aurez un premier sujet
c'est tout simplement les gens pouront
pas ouis les gens pourront pas VO après
dans un monde avec considérablement
moins de pétrole je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le pouvoir d'achat des gens va
baisser en fait c'est ça qui va se
passer et donc peut-être que ils vont
pas privilégier le ski par rapport au
fait de manger d'avoir un logement ou de
pouvoir envoyer leurs enfants à l'école
donc là il y a il y a une question de
solvabilité du consommateur et en fait
on le voit déjà aujourd'hui les stations
qui tirent leur épingle du jeu c'est les
grandes stations qui attirent une
clientèle internationale en quantité
croissante donc en fait les stations qui
s'en sortent bien c'est celles qui
concentrent les riches de la planète en
augmentant leur bilan carbone puisque
les gens viennent d'encore plus loin
c'est quand même paradoxal euh mais avec
une part de la clientèle française qui
s'érode tout simplement parce que le
pouvoir d'achat de mes concitoyens est
déjà en train de ces rodés euh et donc
ça se ressent déjà sur la fréquentation
des stations de ski et à ça vient se
rajouter le sujet de la neige donc la
neige il va effectivement tomber moins
euh parce que la température se
réchauffant il tombe moins de neige
alors ça va poser un certain nombre de
problème pas que pour le ski euh la
neige c'est un stock d'eau qui devient
disponible au printemps et à l'été pour
alimenter la végétation alimenter les
fleuves et et cetera toujours dans la
littérature scientifique dans le dernier
rapport du GC qui portait sur l'océan et
la criryosphère il était montré que par
exemple les débits des TI des fleuves
l'été allait significativement alors
d'abord augmenter à mesure que les
glaciers allaient fondre et puis une
fois que les glaciers auraient bien
fondu après ça allait fortement baisser
on va avoir le même problème avec la
neige c'est-à-dire que les
précipitations d'hiver on plus souvent
de la pluie moins souvent de la neige et
donc ça va pas rester au sommet des
montagnes ça va glisser vers la vallée à
un moment où la végétation en a pas
besoin et le moment où la végétation en
aurait besoin ça sera plus là et il y a
effectivement aussi le problème de
l'économie de ces départements de
montagne où ils vont avoir moins de gens
parce que parce que s'il y a moins de
neige ça sera quand même compliqué de
faire du ski on a tous en tête cette
image un peu surréaliste des Jeux
olympiques d'hiver qui ont eu lieu en
Chine où on voyait une bande de neige
pour le pour la piste de ski au au
milieu de l'herbe bon et ben ça ça
ressemble de plus en plus à ce qu'on
peut trouver dans des stations de ski
grâce aux enneigeurs alors quand vous
avez encore du froid et pas de neige
vous pouvez faire de la neige avec de
l'eau et des enneigeurs ce qu'on appelle
la neige artificielle euh mais par
contre si vous n'avez même plus assez de
froid pour faire de la neige ou si la
neige fond une fois que vous l'avez
faite bah vous avez un vrai problème
donc effectivement il va y avoir un
sujet sur le ski mais la neige va pas
être le seul sujet sur le ski il va
aussi y avoir un sujet strictement
économique et un sujet strictement
physique qui est la la capacité à se
déplacer et la question de la neige
entraîne tout logiquement la question de
la température depuis plusieurs années
on entend ça 2,6°gr au-dessus des
normales en moyenne on est 8 à 10 degrés
ce matin au-dessus des normals de saison
on est sous les normals de saison de 4 à
5 degr ma question que beaucoup se pose
c'est quoi des normales de saison alors
ce qu'on appelle la normale de saison
c'est tout simplement la moyenne sur les
sur 30 ans d'une période de référence je
vis pas dire de bêtisse parce que ça
change en permanence maintenant il me
semble que c'est 1990 2020 maintenant
c'est sous réserve c'est sous réserve
parce que je voudrais être sûr de pas
dire de bêtises mais en gros si on prend
la température moyenne sur les 30
dernières années pour la saison en
question ça fait une valeur donnée et
puis on compare à cette valeur voilà et
donc on dit que on est au-dessus de la
normale de saison si la température
moyenne du mois de juillet par exempleou
du mois d'août est au-dessus de la
moyenne des 30 dernières années et qu'on
est en dessous si voilà la notion même
de normal est quelque chose qui en fait
il va falloir se sortir de la tête parce
que dans un climat qui dérive en
permanence il y a plus de normal si vous
comme dans Dieu sa quel film là que vous
avez votre taille qui diminue d'un
cmètre chaque jour chaque année jusqu'à
la fin de vos jours vous avez chaque
chaque année un CTIM c'est quoi votre
taille normale donc en fait la normale
c'est quelque chose qui fait qui renvoie
à un état stable c'est c'est implicite
on s'en rend pas compte mais en fait
quand on parle de normal ça veut dire
qu'il y a un état stable et que si à un
moment il y a une instabilité c'est pas
grave parce que derrière on revient à la
normale or en fait sur la dérive
climatique on revient viendra jamais à
la normale c'est un truc qui c'est ça a
pas de sens parce que tant qu'on rajoute
une tonne de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère s'enrichit en CO2 parce que
le CO2 s'évacue pas facilement de
l'atmosphère c'est une molécule
chimiquement très stable comme tous les
oxydes et donc la température planétaire
continue à dériver et toutes les
composantes du système climatique qui
dépendent de la température continuent à
dériver donc en fait le le climat ne
peut pas avoir d'État normal tant qu'on
émet ne serait-ce qu'une tonne de CO2
dans l'atmosphère et comme c'est pas
demain matin qu'on va passer à une tonne
de CO2 ou à zé euh compte tenu de tout
ce qu'on s'est raconté sur la dépendance
du monde moderne aux énergies fossiles
même sil faut souhaiter que ça diminue
le plus vite possible et qu'on arrive à
0ro un jour donc ça veut dire que le
climat va continuer à dériver pendant
encore très longtemps et puis il y a des
composantes du climat sur lesquelles
même après arrêt des émissions ça va
continuer à dériver enfin ou des
composants de l'environnement plutôt par
exemple l'adaptation des écosystèmes au
nouveau climat même une fois que le
nouveau climat sera stable l'adaptation
des écosystèmes derrière va prendre des
décennies ou des siècles la montée du
niveau de la mer va perdurer pendant des
milliers d'années après arrêt des
émissions donc ça ça va impacter les
zones littorales comme on l'ai dit tout
à l'heure les submersions marines le
fait qu'il y a des ports ou pas de
pororts parfois parfois les maladies
parfois les maladie parce que ça va
augmenter les osomatres dans un certain
nombre d'endroits et donc augmenter les
épidémies de choléra enfin voilà donc il
y a il y a plein de trucs qui vont
perdurer après arrêt des émissions
longtemps donc alors ça peut paraître un
peu désagréable ce que je suis en train
de dire mais ça veut dire que la notion
de normal en fait n'aura plus vraiment
court et que on pourra parler de normal
pour la moyenne des 30 dernières années
mais même cette moyen changer en
permanence ouis ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que parler de normal de saison ça
n'a sans doute plus trop de sens et
d'ailleurs est-ce que les saisons
existent encore vraiment à quoi ça va
ressembler les saisons plus tard oui en
fait globalement l'été va s'allonger
c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir une période
chaude avec potentiellement des épisodes
caniculaires et des épisodes de
sécheresse qui va augmenter et dans un
scénario de Fort réchauffement l'été au
moyen de latitude passerait de 3 à 6
mois en gros on a un hiver qui va très
fortement se contracter et des
intersaisons qui vont également diminuer
voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est en gros en
terme de répartition dans l'annété
prendre la place l'hiver se se contracte
un peu et se contracte très fortement et
l'intersaison se contracte un peu voilà
ok donc on a parlé des transports des
loisirs et même des saisons on passe
donc à un autre aspect là encore qui
devrait subir de nombreuses évolutions
et ce à mesure que l'énergie issue du
pétrole est en train de se rarifier
c'est la question du logement d'un point
de vue de gestion démographique je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le le bon terme
entre vivre en ville vivre dans des
milieux davantage ruraux et sur
l'évolution de tout cela quelle est la
meilleure option un peu schématiquement
pour pour le climat et et dans un monde
idéal pour s'en sortir est-ce qu'on
ferait mieux d'ê mieux tout ses passer
est-ce qu'on ferait mieux de viv en
ville en fait la réponse à ça elle est
très liée à l'énergie plus qu'au climat
quand on regarde comment était occupé le
territoire français avant l'énergie
abondante il y a quelques siècles on se
rend compte qu'il y avait finalement on
pouvait être dans deux types de schémas
soit on était dans un schéma totalement
rural où là en gros on était pas dans
l'autarciie mais proche de l'autarciie
c'est-à-dire que en fait en fait on
avait l'essentiel de ce qui nous était
nécessaire pour vivre en interagissant
avec des gens qui étaient à faible
distance de là où on était donc les
pierres pour le pour construire son
logement elles étaient pas loin la
charpense pour construire le logement
elle était pas loin paysans étaient pas
des charpentiers mais on le connaissait
il était pas loin l'essentiel des gens
étaient agriculteurs parce que le
premier besoin c'est de se nourrir et
l'agriculture était pas très productive
et puis il y avait quelques personnes
qui échappaient à ce schéma qui étaient
dans le tissu d'échange et ça c'était la
ville donc en fait la ville est un
endroit où on fait des échanges c'est
essentiellement à ça que ça sert on voit
bien que toutes les villes sont
structurées enfin dans dans l'urbanisme
ancien autour de lieu d'échange l'école
on échange des savoirs qui est au centre
de la ville le place de marché où on
échange des biens qui est au centre de
la ville l'église ou la mosquée ou la
synagogue whatever qui est au centre de
la ville aussi où on échange des valeurs
morales et des croyances la
représentation du pouvoir central qui
est aussi au centre de la ville et puis
après les gens sont parce que la ville
sert à faire des échanges bon dans le
monde moderne où on est tous dans le
tertière les machines bossent à notre
place pour faire nos fringues notre
nourriture nos voitures et cetera en
fait tout ce qu'on a à faire nous c'est
de gérer les échanges liés à tous ces
flux physiques monstrueux qu'on a créé
grâce aux machines et donc on s'est tous
mis en ville mais ça ça flotte pas dans
un monde à l'énergie rare dans un monde
à l'énergie rare d'abord il y aura moins
de trucs à échanger il y aura une
complexité moins importante du monde à
gérer on va devoir simplifier le monde
dans un monde à l'énergie rare et par
ailleurs on aura plus par exemple autant
de capacités de transport longue
distance pour alimenter les villes pour
ramener les vêtements pour ramener et
cetera une île de France à 100 millions
d'habitants c'est un truc qui flotte pas
dans un monde à l'énergie très
contrainte d'accord alors bonne question
à ce moment c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des gens ce qu'on a créé sous forme de
banlieu en fait c'est trop peu dense
pour en faire des tissus d'échange
urbain dans un monde à l'énergie rare
mais c'est trop dense pour en refaire
des des paysages agricoles d'accord donc
il y a toute cette question urbanistique
alors pour le moment personne n'a la
réponse je sais pas comment ça va se
passer c'est une question qui est posée
et oui dans un monde à l'énergie
contrainte j'ai envie de dire le le le
paysage général qu'on imagine c'est des
petites villes compactes très
disséminées sur le territoire avec un un
arrière-pays qui permet d'assurer une
plus grande part de la subsistance
immédiate que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc il faut avoir des courgettes du blé
et des poulets un peu partout et pas
juste tous les poulets et tous les
cochons en Bretagne tout le blé ici tout
le maïs là et toutes les courgettes en
Espagne voilà ça c'est un truc qui
marche pas bien dans un monde à
l'énergie contrainte et c'est pareil
pour d'autres d'autres commodités c'est
aussi comme ça que on peut diminuer le
volume global de déplacement ce qu'on va
être obligé de faire en diminuant les
portées des déplacements ce qu'on va
être obligé de faire dans un monde dans
dans un monde à l'énergie plus
contrainte voilà donc on imagine bien
que pour finir le schéma urbanistique
qu'on favorise aujourd'hui encore
c'est-à-dire créer des métropoles qui
soit de plus en plus grosse parce qu'on
se dit que c'est comme ça que on
rivalise dans la compétition
internationale queon a et cetera en fait
c'est quelque chose qui a marché dans le
passé c'est un truc qui marchotte déjà
moins bien aujourd'hui et c'est un truc
qui marchera pas du tout qui prépare pas
du tout l'avenir alors si vous habitant
en métropole c'est sans doute pas la
meilleure solution pour l'avenir plus
sérieusement ce que raconte Jean-Marc
Jancovici ici c'est que dans un monde
avec moins de pétrole les produits dont
on a besoin et bien ne se déplacent plus
donc la courgette venue d'Espagne ne
pourra plus être livrée aussi facilement
jusqu'au Carrefour City à côté de chez
vous il faudra donc habiter au plus
proche des cultures donc dans l'idéal là
où il y a de l'espace pour les cultiver
et une question donc qui vient avec cuid
de notre consommation de viande on sait
que la population doit manger moins de
viande pour limiter son impact sur sur
l'environnement de plus en plus de
personnes évidemment deviennent
végétariennes mais au-delà de celles qui
deviennent végétariennes il y a un enjeu
global à réduire la consommation de
viande est-ce qu'on a aujourd'hui des
ordres de grandeur qui permettent de
voir à quoi ça ressemble aujourd'hui et
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
encourager tout cela à nouveau je vais
repartir du passé entre il y a deux
siècles et maintenant la consommation de
viande par personne en France en gros
était multiplié par 5 nos ancêtres en
1800 manger à peu près 20 kg de viande
par personne et par an aujourd'hui donc
on est passé à un peu moins de 100 kg de
viande par personne et par an alors ça
s'érote très légèrement depuis une
dizaine ou une une une quinzaine
d'années et puis par ailleurs la
composition de ce panier de viande
change il y a plus de volaille moins de
bœuf voilà ça ça ça se modifie pourquoi
est-ce que il faut manger moins de
viande euh alors sur le plan
environnemental je vais pas parler du
plan sanitaire sur le plan
environnemental la possibilité de manger
beaucoup de viande nécessite une
agriculture très productive parce que
évidemment plutôt que de manger une
calorie de lentill ou de poischiche qui
est comme chacun sait l'aliment de la
transition par excellence si vous mangez
une calorie de bœuf et ben il vous aura
fallu 5 10 calories de végétal pour
alimenter votre animal que vous allez
manger donc ça veut dire qu'il faut une
production végétale plus importante
alors ça a été permis par les
combustibles fossiles juste pour donner
un ordre de grandeur entre la production
céréalière par hectare qu'on avait avant
les combustibles fossiles allez on va
dire avant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
celle qu'on avait en 1975 il y a eu un
facteur 5 c'est que la production à
l'hectare a été multipliée par 5
d'accord et aujourd'hui l'essentiel de
culture c'est des cultures qui servent
pas à nourrir des gens un champ de maïs
c'est du maïs fourrage ça sert à nourrir
des animaux une prairie les gens
broutent pas l'herbe ça sert à nourrir
les animaux même si le trèfle c'est bon
les fleurs de trèfle c'est un petit peu
sucré c'est pas mauvais et puis euh
quand vous avez un champ de blé une fois
sur deux il va servir à nourrir des
animaux aussi enfin voilà donc il y a
plein de il y a plein de cultures qui
servent à nourrir les animaux et on peut
se le permettre encore une fois parce
que l'agriculture est très productive
dans un monde où l'agriculture est moins
productive on a le choix entre Contin
continuer à manger autant de viande et
couper toutes les forêts pour avoir plus
de surface pour être toujours capable de
nourrir les animaux qu'on mangeuttre pas
une option géniale ou bien on peut
manger moins de viande al moi je fais
pas partie des gens qui disent faut plus
en manger du tout alors après il y a un
débat sur la souffrance animale et
cetera qui est plus un débat
environnemental c'est autre chose on
peut avoir un long débat pour savoir si
la vache il vaut mieux qu'elle finisse
sa vie en ayant un cancer et des
rhumatismes ou que elle y passe
proprement et rapidement c'est un long
débat non mais et puis il y a des tas de
surfaces qui sont pas valorisables
facilement avec des cultures les
prairies de montagne par exemple vous
allez pas y mettre des chambelés donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les prairies
de montagne on y mettra pas non plus des
skilleurs on vient d'en parler bon donc
l'élevage c'est quand même pas
complètement stupide historiquement pour
valoriser au mieux un certain nombre de
surface par contre aujourd'hui c'est
clair qu'on a un trop gros cheptel et
quand on réfléchit à la baisse de la
consommation de viande il y a un truc
qu'il faut absolument qu'on garde en
tête c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
éleveurs quel est le contrat social
qu'on passe avec les éleveurs dont il
faut rappeler que c'est déjà les
agriculteurs qui gagnent le moins c'est
ceux chez qui il y a le taux de suicide
le plus élevé donc moi je veux bien
qu'on désespère encore plus Bill en
cours mais à un moment il faut quand
même leur dire écoutez les gars on va en
manger moins mais c'est ça ça va pas
vous les dansons de la farce surtout
qu'on a un problème par ailleurs on
vient d'en pararler de entre guillemets
repeuplement des campagnes bon à un
moment il faut accepter que si on mange
moins de viande elle vaut plus cher une
manière de faire ça peut être de mettre
partout des cahers des charges des
labels des trucs comme ça parce que en
général c'est quelque chose qui fait que
le consommateur accepte une valorisation
plus élevée et puis il y a tout la toute
la question des
intermédiaires si on achète la viande
qu'on cuisine nous-même ça coûte
fatalement moins cher globalement que si
on l'achète déjà transformé il y a toute
une réflexion à avoir sur comment est-ce
qu'on réoriente le système autour de ça
si aujourd'hui on dit juste je mange
moins de viande point le système se
enfin je ne mange plus de viande plus
exactement point le système se réoriente
pas nécessairement de la façon la plus
intéressante et encore une fois est-ce
que il faut plus en manger du tout ou
est-ce qu'il faut juste se dire bon
aujourd'hui on en mange deux fois trop
donc on va le diviser par deux et ou on
va le diviser par TR on en mangera
encore de temps en temps mais il y a une
c'est une affaire de proportion alors ça
fait déjà pas mal de temps qu'on discute
et c'est le moment de revenir sur un
sujet qui a fait réagir il y a quelques
semaines à la rentrée elle fait suite à
cette séquence de mon interview
d'emmanel Macron je veux que on est dès
la 6e de cette année qu'on commence à
avoir des élèves qui plantent des arbres
alors j'avais été plutôt critique lors
de l'interview avec cette réponse pas ça
qui inversera la courbe des émissions
mais rien pas plus que ce que vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure sur prendre
moins
d'avion non c'est tous ces gestes ce que
je vous ai dit sur l'avion plus j'évite
un vol inutile plus en effet je reboise
Emmanuel Macron souhaite arriver à 1
milliard d'arbres plantés d'ici 2032 et
nouvelez ainsi à 10 % la forêt française
je tenais donc à demander à Jean-Marc
jankcovissi si oui ou non cette mesure
aurait un impact sur les émissions de
CO2 en France alors la forêt française
si on reprend le problème dans cette
dans sa globalité aujourd'hui la la
forêt française elle capte quelques
dizaines de millions de tonnes de CO2
par an dans un pays qui en émet quelques
centaines de millions pour fixer les
ordres de grandeur et qui euh à peu près
450 et qui en en terme d'empreinte
carbone c'est si on rajoute les
émissions qu' ont lieu chez les autres
et qui servent à fabriquer mon t-shirt
ma ma ma ma casserole et et mon frigo ça
dépasse plutôt 700 d'accord concrètement
donc les arbres ne se firont pas à eux
seuls à absorber toutes les émissions de
CO2 dont la France est responsable mais
pour autant et bien planter des arbres
c'est toujours utile est-ce qu'il faut
planter des arbres la réponse est oui
alors où est-ce qu'il faut les planter
il faut les planter dans la forêt
française pour renouveler les espèces
qui vont mourir de toute façon à cause
du réchauffement climatique vous avez
peut-être entendu parler de la mort des
épicéas qui sont boulottés par les
scolites là qui qui sont des petites
bêtes des insectes le scolite est un
parasite de l'épicéa classique mais
quand l'épicéa est affaibli par des
chaleurs et des et des sécheresses
excessives à ce moment le scolite s'en
donne à cœur joie et l'épicéa finit par
y passer bon on a d'autres arbres qui
vont être affaiblis par le changement
climatique le être par exemple il a
besoin de conditions plutôt fraîches et
plutôt humide manque de peau dans le
réchauffement climatique on va avoir
plutôt chaud et sec le sapin c'est
pareil il aime pas trop une partie des
chaînes vont y passer également
malheureusement et tous ces arbres là il
faut il faut bien il faut les renouveler
alors est-ce qu'il faut faut demander au
collégiens d'aller les renouveler moi je
préfère qu'on demande aux forestiers
d'aller les renouveler après que dans le
cadre de la sortie annuelle des
collégiens ils aent donné un coup de
main au forestiers en plantant un arbre
ça me dérange pas du tout mais c'est
quand même pas à eux qu'on va
pardonnez-moi l'expression laisser les
clés du camion en disant que c'est les
professeurs des des collège qui vont
aller conduire la reforestation de la
forêt française ça et ça ne compensera
pas du coup ce que vous dites en
parallèle il faut et il faut s'occuper
voilà après il y a un deuxième sujet en
ce qui concerne les arbres c'est les
arbres en ville alors ça c'est pas pas
un sujet de production de bois et c'est
pas un sujet de puit de carbone par
contre c'est un sujet de
rafraîchissement de la ville parce que
c'est quelque chose qui permet d'éviter
les zylos de chaleur urbain ça contribue
à ça et ça contribue aussi à déstresser
les gens le verre c'est c'est la
végétation ça déstresse et la vie en
ville est plutôt stressante et avec ce
qui nous attend elle le sera peut-être
encore un peu plus avec d'ailleurs des
inégalités plusieurs études l'ont l'ont
montré inégalité de répartition de ces
espaces verts avec les quartiers les
plus pauvres généralement qui sont plus
bétonnisés et Ain espac vert que les
qutiers les plus les plus absolument et
donc là c'est là c'est un c'est un sujet
j'ai envie de dire de confort
psychologique c'est un sujet de confort
thermique c'est pas vraiment un sujet de
production de bois et c'est pas un sujet
de c'est un peu un sujet de biodiversité
mais pas énormément donc je pense que
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
encore une fois et c'est bon cette
histoire de collégien c'est un peu
anecdotique dans l'histoire mais par
contre le message important c'est qu'il
faut s'occuper de la forêt c'est une
réflexion une réflexion plus large
là-dessus en synthèse il faut tout de
même planter des arbres d'abord parce
que pas mal d'arbres ne survivent pas au
réchauffement climatique il ont donc
besoin d'être renouvelé et ensuite parce
qu'en ville les espaces verts manquent
parfois beaucoup surtout dans les
quartiers les plus pauvres et puisquon
est sur les sujets qui font aussi
l'actualité l'ex président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozi a déclaré il
y a quelques semaines sur C avau sur
France 5 que la première source de
pollution mondiale c'est la
surpopulation combien de milliards
d'habitants peuvent habiter
pacifiquement sur la planète sans nuire
aux équilibres environnementaux de la
planète c'est 9 milliards d'habit nous
sommes 8 milliards 9 milliards
d'habitants dans
11 milliards à la fin du siècle on pense
qu'avec l'augmentation du niveau de
vie les les les gens ont moins d' enfant
mais rien ne le prouve mais même si ça
stabilise à 11 milliards jamais la
planète n'a connu un tel choc
démographique donc je dis que ce sujetl
devrait être au cœur des défis
environnementaux mais on n parle pas
alors on était 2,5 milliards d'êtres
humains en 1950 on est 8 milliards en
2023 on devrait être 9,7 milliards en
2050 et selon l'ONU on pourrait
potentiellement dépasser les 10
milliards en 200 ma question c'est donc
la suivante Nicolas sarcozi a-t-il
raison de pointer du doigt la croissance
de la population mondiale alors
historiquement il a pas tort sauf que il
a pas tort sur les pays
industrialisés c'estàdire si aujourd'hui
au lieu d'avoir 300 millions
d'Américains on en avait 30 millions
c'est évident que les émissions des
États-Unis seraient plus faibles voilà
donc que la démographie joue un rôle oui
par contre est-ce que c'est la
démographie aujourd'hui des pays
africains qui fait les émissions non et
bien en fait lorsque certaines
personnalités politique affirme que le
problème principal c'est la démographie
et bien la plupart du temps il pointe du
doigt des pays en voie de développement
dont notamment des pays africains
puisque ce sont sur ces territoires que
le nombre d'enfants par femme est
souvent le plus élevé donc est-ce que
les pays aujourd'hui à forte démographie
ils sont sans aucune pression sur
l'environnement ça dépend ce qu'on
regarde sur les émissions de gaz à effet
de ser ils sont à très faible pression
c'est très clair l'Afrique sur la
biodiversité c'est beaucoup moins vrai
ils ont déjà une pression significative
sur la biodiversité et là la démographie
elle compte c'est Absolum alors après
une fois que j'ai dit ça j'ai tout dit
et j'ai rien dit parce que la bonne
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon
alors il y a une première chose qu'on
peut faire nous les français c'est aider
dans la limite de ce que la morale
autorise les pays à maîtriser leur
démographie ça ne va pas beaucoup
changer les émissions de gaz à effet de
ser à l'avenir faut bien le comprendre
enfin les émissions des pays occidentaux
mais par contre c'est toujours bon à
prendre parce qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre de pression qui augmente
avec la démographie et donc une des
choses qui pourrait être pertinentes
c'est que l'aide au développement
française se concentre sur les mesures
qui permettent au pays à forte
démographie d'avoir une démographie qui
se calme et là il y a trois mesures qui
sont essentielles c'est l'éducation et
l'émancipation des femmes voilà c'est
vraiment ça un truc plus les femmes sont
maîtresses de leur destin en gros et
moins elles ont envie de faire des
enfants ou en tout cas moins elles ont
la plus elles ont la capacité de pas les
faire quand elles en ont pas envie voilà
il y a une deuxième chose qui euh qui
qui joue c'est dans cette panoplie là
l'accès à des moyens de contraception
voilà mais c'est après on peut buter sur
des histoires religieuse morale et
cetera c'est pas toujours très simple et
enfin la troisème mesure qui est
importante c'est les les mécanismes de
solidarité à large échelle qui fait que
vous comptez pas juste sur vos enfants
pour assurer votre survie à vos vieux
jours ou quand vous êtes malade donc
tout ce qui est sécurité sociale
retraite et cetera donc ces sujetsl on
peut considérer que c'est pas immoral
euh d'aider un certain nombre de pays à
mettre tout ça en place et ça ça a un
impact dou j'ai envie de dire sur la
démographie selon Jean-Marc janovissi
contrôler la démographie des pays en
voie de développement ne diminuerait
donc pas beaucoup les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre tout simplement car ces
pays ont des émissions par habitant bien
moindr que les pays développés comme les
États-Unis ou encore la France donc ça
on peut le faire après qu'est-ce que ça
va changer à l'effort que nous on doit
faire nous occidentaux dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique dans les 30 ans
qui viennent à peu près rien parce que
que dans les 30 s qui viennent on soit 8
9 ou 7 milliards d'humains sur terre
dans un contexte dans lequel il faut
éradiquer la quasi totalité des
émissions de CO2 c'est de toute façon la
révolution chez nous et qui est un peu
plus un peu moins d'africain ça changera
absolument pas le fait que de toute
façon ça doit être la révolution chez
nous voilà donc dire c'est la faute des
Africains qui font trop d'enfants non ça
c'est totalement illégitime c'est
quantitativement inexact par contre dire
si on peut les aider à en faire moins
parce qu'ils le souhaitent et
globalement
ça sera ça de moins pour l'avenir ça oui
mais c'est deux débats différents et par
ailleurs vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
mais il y a la question effectivement du
fait que les populations les plus riches
sont en général les populations qui
polluent
davantagech person alors il faut bien
voir quand même que quand vous avez un
continent avec beaucoup de gens dessus
et qui ont accès à internet ça fait
quand même un réservoir de gens qui ont
envie d'augmenter fortement leur
consommation qui est pas nulle bon et ça
c'est une réalité donc on peut pas faire
comme si ça existait pas mais mais mais
ce qu'on peut faire de mieux aussi dans
ce cadre là ça en plus c'est égoïstement
très intéressant pour nous c'est de
faire en sorte que ces gens-là n'auront
pas envie d'aller voir ailleurs le temps
qu'il fait sans mauvais jeu de mot dans
un monde dans lequel il y a des
disparités importantes économiques et
des dispar éventuellement des
déstabilisations
climatiques et donc dire je prendre un
parallèle qui vaut ce qu' vaut mais
quand on fume un paquet de cigarettes
par jour dire à quelqu'un qui fume une
cigarette par jour tu sais tu devrais
pas fumer c'est pas bon pour toi on est
modérément crédible donc de toute façon
nous on a si on veut être crédible sur
le fait que les Africains modère leur
envie de consommer beaucoup plus
qu'aujourd'hui h la seule chose de
pertinente qu'on puisse faire c'est de
commencer par baisser nous je vois pas
ce qu'on peut faire d'autres qui qui qui
qui soit cohérent avec ça donc la
réponse pour lui oui il faut faire moins
d'enfants autre question à présent une
question qui est assez importante c'est
la question de l'impact économique du
réchauffement climatique que ce soit
alors économique on peut penser
typiquement à l'emploi mais il y a
sûrment d'autres d'autres questions
qu'il soit par des mesures qui seraient
mises en place ou qu'il soit subis d'une
façon d'une autre cet impact du
réchauffement climatique il est présent
c'est une question que je sans forcément
d'aboutissement je vous laisse voir où
estce que vous vouz là-dessus mais
comment est-ce que vous voyez
l'évolution du rapport au travail par
exemple dans les années dans les
décennies qui viennent avec cette
contrainte du réchauffement climatique
alors sur la question du rapport au
travail le climat il va modifier la
possibilité d'exercer certains travaux
euh en France ou ailleurs je vais
commencer par ailleurs pour parce que
c'est il y a un certain nombre de zones
dans le monde où il fait à la fois chaud
et humide c'est toute la bande
équatoriale dans ces pays équatoriaux
vous avez comme partout ailleurs de
l'agriculture du reste vous avez un
certain nombre de pays où l'activité
agricole est beaucoup plus importante
que chez nous en terme de quantité de
main d'œuvre dans un climat qui se
réchauffe dans ces endroits-là il va y
avoir ce qu'on appelle un effet de
thermomètre mouillé c'est-à-dire que un
temps beaucoup plus chaud et beaucoup
plus humide parce que quand il fait plus
chaud il y a plus d'évaporation et donc
il y a plus d'humidité dans l'air ça va
stresser notre corps de manière beaucoup
plus importante à tel point qu'en 2050
il y a 1 milliard d'individus en gros
qui pourraient vivre dans des zones dans
lesquelles plus d'un jour sur deux dans
l'année on peut pas sortir dehors sans
mettre sa vie en danger parce que on se
rapproche d'une temp on est dans des
conditions dans lesquelles la
température extérieure est supérieure à
la température de notre peau ou s'en
rapproche et l'humidité est quasiment de
100 % donc on peut pas se refroidir en
évaporant notre soeur d'ailleurs c'était
déjà dans l'actualité ces derniers mois
il y cas de certaines régions en Inde
enfin pas mal de ça augmente ça augmente
ça ça ça n'arrête pas d'augmenter dans
ces endroits-là le rapport au travail
agricole va être un peu modifié et puis
il y a pas que le rapport au travail
agricole il y a le fait que ça va
déstabiliser la société d'une manière
générale et il y a plein d'autres
travaux je peut pas sortir à l'extérieur
c'est pas pouvoir faire un certain
nombre de travaux d'extérieur donc il y
a ce rapport au travail qui va être
modifié de cette manière-là par les
conditions extérieures ça ça concerne
l'agriculture les travaux publics enfin
un certain nombre de choses après il y a
un deuxième rapport au travail qui peut
être modifié c'est les activités qui
seront utiles à la société vont changer
donc les gens qui font certains qui ont
certaines activités aujourd'hui bah il
est possible que dans 10 20 30 ans on
leur dise ou ils réalisent que euh ça on
en a moins besoin donc il va y avoir
moins d'emplois on parlait tout à
l'heure des stations de ski bah les gens
qui fabriquent des skis dans un monde
dans lequel il y a moins de stations de
ski peut-être queon va avoir moins
besoin d'eux et par contre il y a
d'autres travaux dont on aura plus
besoin on parlait tout à l'heure de la
de la nécessité de modifier
l'agriculture dans un monde qui où
l'agriculture sera éventuellement moins
mécanisée par exemple on va avoir besoin
de plus de monde dans l'agriculture dans
un monde dans lequel on a besoin de
modifier la performance thermique des
logements on a besoin de quelques
centaines de milliers de personnes en
plus dans l'artisanat du bâtiment donc
le rapport au travail il peut aussi être
modifié euh voilà et incidemment s'il y
a beaucoup de jeunes qui écoutent ce
podcast et bien une des choses
importantes dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est tout
simplement le métier qu'on exerce c'est
quelque chose de crucial ça nous occupe
quand même une bonne partie de la
journée et notre contribution à la
société elle se fait beaucoup au travers
du travail qu'on effectue donc voilà ça
c'est un deuxième rapport au travail qui
qui qui peut être modifié par le
changement climatique et plus
généralement par le stress ou les
contraintes qu'on peut avoir sur les
ressources si on résume donc le rapport
au travail va changer déjà parce que
dans certaines zones il fera trop chaud
pour travailler en extérieur puis parce
que certains métiers seront tout
simplement moins utiles par exemple des
saisonniers dans les stations de ski à
l'inverse certains secteurs demanderont
de la main d'œuvre en plus dans le
bâtiment par exemple puisqu'on doit
rénover de nombreux logements ce qui
entraîne donc ma dernière question quel
regard de la même façon est-ce que vous
portez sur ce débat et ce sujet
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on a eu beaucoup
d'ESS mé Paris qui me semble qui a fait
un ESS sur le sujet il y a y a quelques
mois quel regard est-ce que vous portez
sur la question de la croissance
économique et du respect de de
l'environnement et de ces accords qu'on
a historiquement la croissance
économique significative elle est
arrivée dans les pays qui se sont
industrialisés le premier pays en Europe
qui a vu son économie commencer à
croître de manière significative c'est
la Grande-Bretagne au moment de sa
premierè sa révolution industrielle
quand elle a commencé à taper dans son
charbon et c'est globalement ce qui
s'est constaté à peu près partout dans
le monde c'està-dire que en fait la
croissance économique c'est une marque
de l'anthropocène c'est quelque chose
qui est arrivé parce qu'on a eu des
sources d'énergie beaucoup plus denses à
notre disposition et donc on a pu mettre
les machines au travail augmenter la
quantité de table de chaises de mètres
carrés et de de casserole qu'on
produisait plus tout le reste derrière
et on voit bien que dans un monde avec
moins d'énergie l'énergie étant par
définition en physique la marque d'un
d'une transformation c'est ça sa
définition en physique si on a moins
d'énergie on transforme moins et si on
transforme moins et qu'on continue à
valeur au même prix tout ce qu'on
transforme bah on a moins d'économie
voilà c'est aussi bête que ça alors on
peut dire oui mais ok on fera moins de
casserole les gens iront plus au musée
alors ça ça marche qu'un temps parce
qu'on se rend compte que il y a quand
même une hiérarchie des besoins et que
on peut pas complètement substituer des
mètres carrés de logement par des
visites au musée je vous dis vous allez
vous allez dormir dehors mais c'est pas
grave vous allez au musée vous allez
être très content non peut-être pas que
ça va peut-être pas macher comme ça donc
en fait il y a un certain nombre de
choses si on en a moins
quelle que soit la façon dont on
valorise l'économie on va comprendre que
l'économie est moins prolixe quelque
part mais alors quand est-ce que cette
décroissance va arriver alors quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en Europe
malheureusement ou heureusement je ne
sais pas cette décroissance a déjà
commencé ça c'est quelque chose que peu
de gens savent peu de gens réalisent
sauf ceux qui vivent effectivement les
difficultés au quotidien ils ont très
bien réalisé mais dans le milieu des
décideurs où ils vivent pas les
difficultés au quotidien en fait ils
s'en rendent pas nécessairement compte
quand vous regardez la quantité de
mètres carrés construit par an en Europe
le maximum c'était 2007
quand vous regardez la quantité de
tonnes chargées dans les camions les
tonnes chargées dans les camions en fait
c'est un agrégat de tout ce que produit
l'industrie à la fois l'industrie
l'industrie agroalimentaire et cetera
c'est le maximum était 2007 aussi alors
pourquoi 2007 tout simplement parce
qu'en 2007 c'est là qu'on est passé par
le maximum de l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen encore constitué
aujourd'hui au 3/4 d'énergie fossile
parce qu'on a eu la conjonction du pic
de production du pétrole dans le monde
hors pétrole de schiste et sa humin
canadien tout le reste est passé par un
maximum en 2008 pour être plus précis
parce qu'on a eu le pic de production de
la mer du Nord en gaz en 2005 et parce
que le charbon était déjà en déclin en
Europe depuis les années 50 bien avant
qu'on commence à s'exciter sur le
changement climatique tout simplement
parce qu'il y en avait plus dans les
mines ou plus assez dans les mines donc
en fait l'approvisionnement européen
énergétique il est en contre et le
nucléaire qui baisse aussi en Europe et
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables qui
augmentent sont pas suffisants pour
compenser ce déclin surtout pas le
nucléire puisqu qu'il baisse et pas les
nouvelles énergies renouvlaables puis en
plus il y a un problème climatique qui
fait que l'hydroélectricité sode un peu
aussi bon donc si on met tout ça bout à
bout on se rend compte que
l'approvisionnement énergétique européen
il baisse depuis 2008 c'est voilà c'est
ça s'rode ce qui du reste incidemment
pour moi est une des explications de la
crise financière de 2009 quand on
regarde bien les flux physiques
sous-jacents dans l'économie ça
s'explique à ce moment on comprend que
c'est pourquoi c'est en 2009 et pas en
2010 en 2011 en 2012 ou en 2005 on
arrive à comprendre et donc cette
décroissance malheureusement on est déjà
en train de la vivre alors moi qui fait
partie des AF bourgeois je m'en rends
pas compte dans mon quotidien mais il y
a déjà une partie des gens dans ce pays
qui s'en rendent compte et du reste le
revenu disponible des ménages est déjà
en train de baisser depuis 2010 il
baisse depuis 2010 ça fait plus de 10
ans qu'il baisse d'accord donc en fait
la décroissance malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas en tout cas
elle est déjà là dans notre pays et je
pense qu'elle va s'amplifier pour des
raisons énergétiques et la bonne
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on en
tient compte dans les plans qui nous
empêchent quand même pas d'être heureux
pour l'avenir parce que il s'agit pas
d'être un C bonbon
et de et de juste dire ben vous allez
avoir moins et puis soyez voilà
démerdez-vous faut quand même enfin on
est des êtres ayant besoin d'espoir
ayant besoin de projet il ont besoin de
de se projeter et on peut pas juste se
contenter en disant bah les cocos vous
allez avoir moins puis démerdez-vous
avec ça mais tous les gens qui
aujourd'hui font des plans collectifs
ils doivent à mon avis intégrer le fait
que ça doit flotter dans un monde dans
lequel on a moins de ressources d'accord
et aujourd'hui la désillusion elle vient
du fait qu'on continue à se raconter
c'est juste un mauvais moment à passer à
attendons donc un an 2 ans 3 ans
faites-moi confiance élisez-moi et
cetera et ça repartira dans l'autre sens
non ça repartira pas structurellement
dans l'autre sens et je j'insiste alors
je pense que ça nous empêche pas d'être
heureux en tout cas pas pendant un
certain temps par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est que si on en tient pas compte dans
le nos grands plans d'architectes
économique pour l'avenir on va se
prendre des baffes parce que il va nous
arriver des choses qui sont pas ce qui
va vraiment physiquement se passer alors
avec cet entretien l'objectif c'était de
vous offrir un aperçu du monde à venir
dans un contexte de changement
climatique et d'épis du pétrole j'en
suis conscient ça peut provoquer chez
certains d'entre vous un certain
pessimisme du coup c'était sympa aussi
de finir avec une touche un peu plus
vivante alors pourquoi s rire et bien
parce qu'on lui a fait une petite
surprise on a Christophe Blin qui est
présent qui est présent aussi
ici alors ce qui est très drôle je
devais vous quitter pour aller le voir
alors ça c'est quand même drôle
Christophe Blin c'est donc un auteur et
dessinateur de BD c'est lui qui a a
co-écrit le monde sans fin avec
Jean-Marc jankovissi le livre le plus
vendu de l'année 2022 en France une BD
qui aborde bien la question de la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et la
question donc du changement climatique
je dois le dire et je dis pas là parce
que sinon ensuite il va me faire des
misères quand on sera hors caméra mais
qui a trouvé dans le monde sans fin un
certain nombre d'astuces qui m'ont
impressionné sur sa capacité à illustrer
des trucs auquels je je me suis dit
comment il va se démerder avec ça alors
je vais pas vous parler de l'énergie je
vais vous parler des gaz à effet de
serre comment vous voulez dessiner un
truc qui se voit pas et qui se sent pas
je me suis dit je vois pas comment il va
s'en sortir et en fait il est arrivé
quand même je dessine un gaz à effet de
serre en fait le gaz à effet de serre
déjà bon c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement invisible et inerte comme
l'expliquéit Jean-Marc et dont on a
beaucoup de mal à se débarrasser mais le
gaz à effet de serre est-ce qu'il est
méchant est-ce qu'il est gentil non on
en a besoin du gaz à effet de serre
parce que s'il y avait pas de gaz à
effet de serre la chaleur ne pourrait
pas
rester au niveau de la terre et et donc
dans la dans la moitié de la du globe
qui est plongé dans la nuit ça serait
glacial donc on a besoin d'avoir de la
chaleur qui reste près du sol donc ce
gaz n'est a priori il est il a quelque
chose de bénéfique mais on comprend bien
que s'il est en excès ben euh on a trop
chaud et on cuit et ce gaz à eff ser ne
bouge pas il est ni méchant ni gentil
mais euh et donc il est très difficile à
représenter donc il est invisible j'ai
fait des petits points mais en fait il
est
dépressif il est parfaitement dépressif
il est il est ni sympathique ni
antipathique il est dépressif on
n'arrive pas à le bouger ça c'est des ça
fait partie des astuces que j'ai trouvé
en écoutant Jean-Marc mais il faut
savoir que j'ai pas trouvé des astuces
seul parce que Jean-Marc a un langage
qui est très imagé justement pour
expliquer des choses qui sont très
complexes notamment le fait qu'on soit
dépendant des machines et donc l'énergie
comme il l'a expliqué l'énergie c'est
les machines les machines sans même
qu'on s'en rende compte sans même qu'on
y pense
ell nous entourent en permanence la
preuve on est en train de parler dans
des micros pour que des gens qui sont
très loin de nous à un autre moment nous
voient nous
entendre on le fait à tout moment on se
déplace on prend une voiture sans même
s'en rendre compte en fait c'est comme
si on avait un exosquelette qui
multipliait nos capacités physiques qui
sont finalement à l'échelle humaine
relativement limité on n'est pas capable
d'avoir une force physique énorme par
rapport à ce qu'on fait on voit un
immeuble se construire des des des
tonnes de de de béton ou de pierres être
soulevé par des des machines on trouve
ça banal on est en ville on voit ça
c'est un paysage quotidien or en fait ce
sont des super pouvoirs et l'image
qu'avait trouvé Jean-Marc c'est dire
qu'on avait un exosquelette dont se
rendrait pas compte et qu'on était des
super-héros quel super-héros
a un exo qui est un humain presque
normal mais à un exosquelette euh
en permanence qui lui permet une armure
qui lui permet d'être un super-héros
c'est Iron Man et donc Iron Man est
devenu un des personnages centrale de la
bande dessinée et cette trouvaille elle
a c'est c'est Jean-Marc il a mis
quelques quelques moi la trouvé dans ses
conférences il utilisait un jour il
s'est dit tiens je sa pas quand est-ce
que tu t'es dit ça Iron Man était la
meilleure façon d'expliquer que
l'énergie était
importante au-delà même de ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer et qu'on la on n
pensait pas alors qu' en fait on était
des super-héros sans savoir en
permanence alors c Iron Man je lui ai
mis un un grand nez parce que dans le la
bande dessiné c'est moi je me dessine
toujours avec un grand nez et c'est moi
qui rev l'armure et qui l'essaye et que
il a une figure très plate Iron Man pour
faire passer le alors en réalité c'est
pour des problèmes de droit parce qu'il
faut bien comprend que Marvel nous
attaque pas et qu'on comprenne que c'est
une que c'est que que c'est que c'est
une parodie donc pour que le personnage
soit strictement parodique et qu'on
puisse l'utiliser c'était aussi une
astuce et puis ça permet de de mettre un
élément euh comique et de et que le
personnage soit très bien identifier
donc finalement dans les premières pages
du livre
euh je je je jeanmarque m'explique il me
dit qu'est-ce que c'est que l'énergie
qu'est-ce qui symbolise l'énergie bah
c'est les machines qui nous entourent et
il m'emmène dans un endroit il disent
c'est cette armure C cette armure d'Iron
Man euh donc l'énergie c'est Iron Man
nous sommes tous nous sommes tous dans
le monde moderne dans nos nos pays
civilisés là vous Jean-Marc moi nous
sommes des Iron Man sans nous en rendre
compte nous avons constamment un
exosquelette qui multiplie nos
démultiplie nos capacités nous sommes
tous des Iron Man mais jusqu'à quand
dureront nos pouvoirs c'est là-dessus
qu'on va conclure cette vidéo si ce
format nous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner c'est pas encore le cas à cette
nouvelle chaîne Youtube et à nous dire
dans les commentaires j'ais vouler un
deuxième épisode avec un deuxième invité
pour suivre l'actualité au quotidien
rendez-vous sur notre autre chaîne
Youtube que je vous mets directement en
description enfin rendez-vous sur notre
newsletter aussi pour recevoir
l'essentiel de l'actualité chaque jour
par email aussi je vous mets le lien en
description prenez soin de vous prene
proches et puis on se dit à très
vite